Hello Freak bitches.
It is what it was.
Just like any other problem that people go back to.
I mean at some point it's up to you to release yourself from that obligation to
get upset or feel bad about something that didn't go right in the past,
you know?
And uh,
that's a huge point because people define themselves by the past instead of
thinking about who they are now instead of they still look back at a mistake
they made and don't just get past that mistake,
grow and learn,
but dwell on it.
I think it defines them.
That's the worst thing I met some guys in band,
he says is a singers.
I've only met him twice,
two different times,
a years later.
Both Times.
He started telling me about the story,
about what happened to him when he was in this.
Anything in this poor guy is gone on all these years and he's still focused on
the worst situation that he ever had to live through.
Yeah.
And it's so a attached to it.
Well some guys get one break up and they're done.
Some guys,
one breakup in their twenties will tank them for a decade.
I've met guys like that that,
yeah.
You know,
I came out here with Sally and you know,
she fucking fell in love with their trainer and dude,
Sally still on.
What is that in fucking years ago.
Oh,
well,
you know,
changed my life bro.
But totally,
totally.
I was so disappointed I can't trust women anymore.
Oh,
you stupid.
Fuck.
You know what?
What if he got mugged by one person who'd done trust in people?
One person was a murderer.
Let's not trust anybody.
Yeah,
yeah.
I heard about Ted Bundy.
I'm not trusting people anymore.
Oh,
okay,
great.
I'm not sleeping tonight.
We,
yeah,
I mean there's definitely pitfalls in life.
You're going to run into him.
We all are.
And you can learn and grow.
If you survive it,
pick yourself up yet,
dust the dust off and then you start going and I don't let this stuff,
uh,
well let it beat you down.
It's also directly proportionate to the amount of hardships that people face in
life.
Their ability to face hardships.
You know,
and there's a lot of folks that live life on a cushy cloud of marshmallows and
bullshit and then one day something goes wrong and I mean that's why spoiled
kids are so sad.
Like a spoiled young boy is one of the saddest things ever.
A young boy that becomes a man and can't take care of himself and his dad has to
keep on rescuing him.
His Dad has to keep on bailing them out of situations and giving them money.
I've met guys like that and that is a crippling affliction when they don't have
the character themselves to be able to get by in life.
They constantly need someone to help them and bailed them out.
Even as a grown man,
I've met guys in their forties it's still need help from their parents.
I'm like,
what the fuck,
man,
you're never going to get it right because somewhere along the line they didn't
face enough of the university to realize that there's sometimes we just got to
get up and get shit done.
There's sometimes we have to fucking pull yourself up and you have to push
forward.
Even if you want to stay in the bed,
and if you don't do that and you just keep calling on your daddy and your daddy
keeps rescuing you,
you never developed those tools,
you never developed that ability to recognize what you're doing wrong with your
life.
What's your age limit?
You would cut a check off at a think I think around 55 whoa.
You're a generous man.
I mean it all depends.
It all depends on if she goes to yoga.
There's a,
there's some good looking 55 out there are now.
Yeah,
there are now scientific.
Have you seen Christie Brinkley?
Yes,
and that's exactly the type of thing I'm talking about.
How old's Christie Brinkley know she's up there.
She's hot as fuck.
He Seen Helen Hunt lately.
No,
I don't need to do that.
There's this movie called,
he's trying to kill my boner.
Frank Lucas bringing up Helen Hunt.
You're going the wrong way,
but you got to hear this picture of Christy blanket to cleanse my palette.
There's this,
let's take this conversation slow.
This is getting exciting.
There was this movie called,
uh,
the session and if you just look up the preview of it,
it's a about this guy that has an iron lung and he's,
you know,
he's very like Stephen Hawking and then maybe just laying there,
Greg Hall and stuff.
And so Helen Hunt's like his therapist or something and he goes,
she's like,
oh,
you need to get laid.
So she starts taking off her clothes and you see her full Bush.
Her body movie is this,
it's called the session.
It's just an old movie.
Oh,
this came out like two years ago and it's just Helen Hunt fucking this retarded.
Not Retarded.
I this iron lung guy and it's just creepy as fuck.
It's just a creepy version of Helen Hunt or face looks weird.
Like,
okay.
And then you just see her Bush and she's having sex for the whole movie.
Pull up that picture.
Sounds pretty good.
Christie.
Christie Brinkley Bitch disgusting me.
That's,
yeah,
that's current.
Okay.
And she's gotta be how old?
She's old and her throat though.
Whatever,
whatever.
Did Banana throw it,
a little tuck.
This validates my hair scarf,
getting rid of the horse riding.
I would make her drive in a convertible and chase me around while I drove
station wagon up town girl.
Well,
if you compare the way she looks today and the way she looked when she was with
Billy Joel,
not that difference.
Compare the way Billy Joel looks today and the way Billy Joel looked when he was
with Christie Brinkley.
I think she's a vampire and then she stole a soul.
Do you think this threat things caused by cock just tons of caucus age,
bro,
your skin gets bad.
She's a 60 years old,
most likely she's 60 years old,
don't you?
Can't you don't respond to him with,
it's amazing.
She looks fantastic.
Absolutely.
That's as good as a 60 year old woman has ever looked in the history of the
world and that's what I mean.
We're talking about exceptions.
When I say,
yeah,
you're not looking at her and going,
oh,
she looks good for 60 you're looking at her and goes,
damn,
she looks really good.
She's hot.
She's hot and her body's really nice too.
Yeah.
Christy full Shiran.
Kapow Kapow I'll take it.
I'll take it all day long.
Yeah.
You make out with her.
I take that throat cutter.
It's a prayer.
It's not that bad dude or throw.
It doesn't look bad.
You're focusing on the wrong thing.
Yeah.
What do you,
you got to mirror,
bitch.
You're going to be very unfocused on that throat.
Gutters.
Weird.
Yeah.
It ain't that bad,
dude.
Come on.
She's hot as fuck.
You're out of your mind.
You look at their neck,
you're looking at a still image cares.
Tom Shaffer.
Knack of it,
Brian.
That's nothing you're saying nothing.
You're making noise with your face.
You really frustrating me right now,
Brian.
Yeah,
there's nothing going on with what you're saying.
You just fixating on next.
Next get a lot worse.
We'll do whatever you want.
Okay,
so we'll vote for you.
We'll do whatever you want.
You just gotta do this first.
We'll listen to you.
Just give her a big fucking jar of them with apple sauce mixed in.
Look at her.
The Joe Rogan kind of hot in a weird milfy way.
No.
I can look at it as people's necks.
That's not even a real bro.
Use Photoshop that he did.
Brian.
Brian,
you hit the volume.
Jesus Christ.
What happened?
You fucking,
it's like a big Dick.
Their volume.
That Mexican fine.
Yeah.
Um,
did you have the headphone didn't effect the recording?
No.
Just the headphones.
You Photoshop that you fuck?
No,
I did.
I think we're stupid.
That's a vagina.
It's on a Mac.
It's luckily she swallowed a bow and Arrow that's going on in her neck.
There's a guy named Merrill Hill.
No,
no,
it's not.
That's Christy.
Is it real?
It is.
No,
it's a real fun.
Did you really doctor that up?
Yeah,
of course it did you fuck how he thinks?
It's funny.
So I'm mature,
man.
He put a vagina at a woman's neck and a woman who's running for Congress,
first of all,
it's unpatriotic.
Regardless whether or not you agree with her,
you will respect her.
It's UNAMERICAN Brian.
Oh,
sorry.